what's up guys today we are going to be
taking a look at the best ur you know
why you shape desk this desk can also be
bought without the you add-on so if you
guys are interested in just the l-shaped
portion to make sure check out my review
of it by clicking in the link in the
description I don't want to stall any
longer so let's jump right in
starting off this desk is very big due
to the nature of it having three full
sites it measures in at fifty nine point
eight inches by eighty four point nine
inches so right about five feet by 7
feet and it is sixty six point four
inches tall the hot side has usable dust
depth of eighteen inches and other aside
has usable desk that space depth of
nineteen point seven five inches at the
deepest portions and sixteen inches of
the shallowest portions the last site
has usable desk top of 26 inches it
comes with the hutch that has four small
storage areas which each measure in at
fourteen point two five inches by three
point one two five inches on top of that
there are four largest storage areas and
two of them have a door these
compartments measured in at fourteen
point two five inches by twelve point
five inches there are also two drawers
on the hot side for both drawers measure
in at 12 by 15 inches and a bottom
drawer does have a lock and comes with
two keys their drawers have ball bearing
slides which makes the sliding smooth
and quiet the maximum height that you
can store underneath the hutch the top
bar installed is anything up to sixteen
point seven five inches without the top
bar you guys can store an extra two
inches or a total of eighteen point
seven five inches there is a sliding
keyboard holding tray which measures in
at twenty seven inches by fourteen point
seven five inches and allows for a
maximum clearance of 2.75 inches from
the ground
you get thirteen point two five inches
of clearance under the drawers and you
guys get twenty seven inches of
clearance under your desk itself as for
the surface itself it is a
commercial-grade surface but
unfortunately smudges are clearly
visible on the surface but it is easily
cleanable but it's still annoying to do
the desk that you guys are seeing right
here is in a clerk Tuscany brown and
black there is another color option
available as well which is called
Antigua
it has a grayish colored surface what
brush-like design on the surface and the
hutch supports and drawers are all white
ask for assembly this desk is very
annoying and takes many many hours for
me it took around 10 hours to fully
assemble the desk but I was working
alone and it wasn't too keen on
finishing it quickly if you guys like
building stuffs like me then assembling
it is not that bad and it feels
rewarding when you're a completely done
building however if you guys don't enjoy
building and just want the function that
desk provides then it is very annoying
and you guys are gonna have a hard time
with it plus something that makes it
even worse is that all the parts in this
desk are very heavy so it's very hard to
be able to move around and assemble
however once you are done it is very
sturdy and can support a lot of weight
this desk is just perfect for computer
users the larger working area makes it
ideal for multiple monitors setups and
is really quite beneficial for even
physical work like drawing schoolwork or
even working with lot of papers finally
I have the hutch on the left side but
since this desk is reversible you can
have the hutch on the right side and
ayub portion on the left side now let's
talk about some areas of this desk is
lacking first of all while the desk
looks great the materials aren't the
absolute best the wood is particle board
and a plastic isn't the best either also
the underneath portion of the desk is
not in the same nice wood finish at the
top is it's actually just white finally
some portion of a desk aren't perfectly
aligned like the door but those are just
pretty much the only issues at this desk
and that's about it for all the features
and negatives of this desk now let's
talk about price you can get this desk
on Amazon right now for just over $600
and there's free shipping the free
shipping is not bad at all actually it's
actually excellent the shipping company
calls you the day before and it's very
inflexible nice however do keep in mind
that they will not put this inside your
house because that's against the policy
so they will only come as far as the
door there's Express assembly available
as well which cost ninety six point five
nine dollars however on the l-shaped
desk review I recommend that you guys
just build it yourself please for some
odd reason the SEM
cost one hundred and sixty-two dollars
for the desk despite it being less work
the assembly is very long and as a
result if you guys really just don't
want to do it or don't want to deal with
all the heavy pieces it may actually be
worth it for you guys to purchase the
experts template in this scenario but
otherwise you guys should just make sure
to get a friend to help you assemble
this because the pieces are just so
heavy and it would be very hard to
handle it alone
so as you can see this desk is quite
great and offers a lot of space for
computer users and gives much more
premium look do is due to its wood like
look combined with the hutch while being
at a price that is quite reasonable as
well as a result should you buy this the
answer to this question is very simple
if you guys are looking for a u-shaped
desk for a nice computer powerhouse
workstation that has a hutch that's a
nice finish and good construction while
not the best and it's not even close to
$1,000 or exceeding it then this is the
perfect desk for you it will serve your
purposes very well and definitely keep
you satisfied for many years if you guys
don't think you need this much space
then you guys just consider you're
getting just the l-shaped portion
however then you shape add-on for this
desk it's really a value buy basically
gives you a lot of space for not that
much more money as a result I would
recommend getting the floor u-shaped
desk if you have yourself that space and
money or even consider adding it on in
the future however if you guys are
looking for the most premium desk with
the best materials or if you guys are
okay with cheaper IKEA desks that don't
look as good but perform the same
function then you guys should still
consider this because even if you want
the best this is one of the best values
out there so while it's not the best in
materials it will save you a lot of
money and if you guys looking for
cheaper desks then this is just so much
better for not that much more money so
you guys should definitely consider it
as well overall in my opinion this is
the best value you shape desk in the
market and it's a great Buy and if you
guys are looking for value then you guys
should definitely buy this buy fake rave
quality or just don't want to spend this
much money on a desk then you guys
should look elsewhere well guys that's
all I have for you guys about this desk
make sure to check out my review on
l-shaped desk if you guys are interested
in the buying this desk the features are
almost identical but my thoughts on that
desk
a little bit different if you guys have
any questions about this desk
make sure leaving a comment section down
below I read all my comments so I answer
to the best of my own but really but
that's all I have for you guys this time
if you guys like this video make sure to
give it a like if you guys loved it and
would like to see more videos just like
this and then make sure to subscribe and
hit the bell notification but that's all
I have for you guys this time and until
next video
bye